Rather than seeing the world in the immediate
aftermath of Thanos' attack, Avengers 4 might
take us back to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
five years into the new status quo.
Is the latest rumor true?
Let's break down the possibilities.
Big casting clues
One possible confirmation of the five-year
time jump rumor comes thanks to the movie's
casting.
While Scott Lang's daughter, Cassie, has been
played thus far by Abby Ryder Fortson in the
two Ant-Man films, the superhero daughter
could be growing up fast suspiciously fast.
In April 2018, just before the release of
Infinity War, news leaked that Marvel had
cast a new actress, Emma Fuhrmann, as Cassie
for Avengers 4.
On its own, this isn't huge news the MCU has
recast roles before but Fuhrmann happens to
be seven years older than her predecessor
in the role.
That's a big jump, all-but-confirming that
this story plans on aging Cassie, quickly.
It's a fairly abrupt shift, considering the
younger actress just played the role in Ant-Man
and the Wasp, which takes place during the
events of Infinity War.
If the sequel starts where Avengers 3 left
off, then why would they need such an older
performer?
Add in a time jump, and it all makes sense.
A Thanos... paradise?
So what would a five-year gap between the
two Avengers sequels mean for the story?
For one thing, we'd get a serious look at
how people have adjusted to half of the universe
being gone.
While grief can last for a lifetime, five
years is a long time to get over some initial
shock.
This way, we'd actually see the lasting effects
of the Avengers' devastating loss.
Lots of rumors about the movie revolve around
beating Thanos with time travel, which sounds
like the smart move.
But what would the ethical implications be
of erasing years of experience from the Infinity
War's survivors, years after the universe
has begun to move on?
It could throw a wrench into the Avengers'
plans for fixing things.
The story of Stark
Aside from Thanos himself, the most important
character in Infinity War is arguably Tony
Stark.
The movie begins with him and Pepper talking
about the future, thinking about having a
child and contemplating retirement.
But retirement looks a lot different when
your last battle ends in your biggest loss.
We don't know if Pepper survived the snap,
but if she did, it's possible that the couple
could have moved on from Infinity War by having
a child.
If the movie starts five years after the war,
then Tony would face a devastating decision
what if saving the universe meant giving up
his kid?
Would he really sacrifice his own flesh and
blood just to pal around with Peter Parker
again?
Well, Aunt May, maybe.
But Pete?
Battle of New York Part II
While we really don't know where Avengers
4 is going, there have been enough set leaks
to give us some huge clues.
For months, we've seen photos of the production
apparently shooting a new version of The Avengers'
climactic Battle of New York, with old costumes
and hairstyles on set further affirming that
we've seen some of this before.
How they do it, we don't know.
But unless Marvel is playing eleven-dimensional
chess and leaking monumental misdirection,
it's almost definitely going to happen.
The idea of a five-year time jump adds some
fuel to the time travel argument.
After all, if the movie involves time travel,
then who cares what time it is when the story
starts?
It could be five years into the future or
fifty years, and all still end happily on
the same day the Infinity War started.
Think Back to the Future, think Terminator.
As soon as going back in time is on the table,
all the problems of a time jump can be undone
just like that.
The sidelined Avenger
After sitting out Infinity War, Avengers 4
will finally see the return of Clint Barton
— but not necessarily Hawkeye.
At this point, it's all but certain that Jeremy
Renner will be coming back as Ronin, a samurai-inspired
character whose mantle has been taken up by
quite a few people in the comics including
Hawkeye.
Hawkeye sat out Infinity War while living
under house arrest with his loving family
following the events of Civil War.
But what if Thanos' attack destroyed his family?
Would the snap make Hawkeye snap?
We think so.
And we think it's going to be awesome.
A five-year gap and a family in the fridge
would provide a perfect cover for the development
and re-emergence of a completely retooled
Barton.
After all, the man really just wants to be
with his family, right?
Not only would a time jump give him space
to train in the ways of the samurai, the loss
of his loved ones could also turn him into
a lawless badass with nothing to lose, back
in action as an Avenger-but-for-real-now.
If this is how it happens, he'd need a little
time to develop that new persona.
If the five-year rumor is true… the timeline
could fit.
To us, this time-jump rumor is pretty compelling.
But there's one aspect about the theory that
gives us pause.
One thing Infinity War lacked during its two-and-a-half
hour runtime was a proper reunion between
Steve Rogers and Tony Stark.
The last time the two were in the same room,
they were more or less trying to murder each
other.
And that was way back in 2016.
By the time Infinity War rolled around, Stark
was still reluctant to pick up the phone and
make the call to his "friend from work."
By the end of the movie, they've both lost
and they still haven't reunited.
The problem with a five-year time jump is
simple audiences want to see Steve and Tony
hug it out.
Would they really skip such an anticipated
reunion by starting the movie in the future?
Or would the two somehow still be avoiding
each other, five years later?
You can't jump that far into the future and
tell us Captain America and Iron Man haven't
made up yet …can you?
It's like, grow up, guys, the world is ruined.
Have a beer and talk it out.
It is possible that the two heroes could avoid
each other for five whole years.
Or maybe the movie skips ahead five years
after Tony returns to Earth, and Tony and
Cap have regrouped.
One way or another, audiences need that scene.
Would a time jump really deny it to us?
Maybe.
But knowing these movies, it might end up
being worth it no matter how things actually
go down.
We'll see what happens when Avengers 4 lands
in 2019.